[Music]
Herry hook is definitely the eye candy
of descendants but just how much do you
know about him from having siblings to
actually having an American accent we'll
show you some facts you never knew about
everyone's favorite descendants pirate
don't forget to hit that notification
bell to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
the back story behind Harry hook
Harry hook in the movie as it turns out
Harry hook in the movie and Harry hook
from the books aren't really the same
people well they are but a lot of his
backstory is actually lost along the way
in order to stick to the most important
vids let's start with checking out what
Harry hook was presented in the movies
and then we'll continue with the books
Harry hook just like his last name might
suggest is actually Captain Hook's son
he's got quite an agenda to him and he
definitely isn't afraid to snatch
someone with his hook which in case you
didn't know is totally fake and just a
homage to his father Harry is quite a
layered character coming with tons of
personality despite the fact that it
might not be the most positive one we're
introduced to Harry as a manipulative
and slightly wild kid but as loyal as a
pirate can be he belongs to Emma's gang
and he's extremely proud and protective
of his friends we also learned that
there might be some backstory to Harry
and mouths relationship which was
actually created by the cast themselves
dove Cameron and Thomas Doherty actually
created a backstory you won't find in
either books or the movies it helps them
develop on-screen chemistry but as far
as we know the backstory is something
you'll probably never see play out Harry
actually dated now before mal dated Ben
she was his first love and they were
both attracted to each other because
well they were both rotten to the core
dub said that they were kind of like
Johnny Depp and Wynonna writer in the
sense that they were madly in love
they even got secret hook tattoos no one
knows about and then mal broke Harry's
heart which made Harry even more mean
and more out of control speaking of
control did you know that Harry was a
supposed to have an American accent but
Thomas Doherty rejected it and went with
a Scottish accent instead this takeover
totally earned him his role in the movie
and were so glad he did it we don't know
much about Harry's relationship with his
father or his mother at least not from
the movies but we do know that the hook
pays homage to the one and only Captain
Hook so we can only assume Harry and his
father were fairly close
unlike other villains Harry also doesn't
possess any typical magical powers
instead he seems to be very skilled at
things that relate to him being a pirate
which is totally understandable
considering that's pretty much all he
knows as he's pretty much born and
raised as a pirate Harry is skilled in
fencing and he's also shown he's able to
totally find his way when it comes to
navigation and all those things
definitely come in handy when you're in
combat mode with the rest of his pirate
crew we're hoping that the third movie
will give us some more insight into
Harry hook and his past life but if it
doesn't we have the books that have
definitely done so Harry hook in the
books you see we do find out a bit more
about Harry hook from the actual
descendants books so if you've never
read them you should give them a shot in
the novels Harry actually has to blame
he's the middle child and has an older
sister called Harriet and a younger
sister named CJ yep that's right
according to the books Harriet can be
quite mean-spirited but not much more is
revealed about their relationship
although we have a feeling there's a
reason why Harry has such tough skin and
Harriet might be it how crazy is this
you know how he said mal and Harry were
actually once lovers well this didn't
happen in the books either it's a brand
new story invented by the actors to help
them stay in their characters and have
some chemistry but the one person Harry
is loyal to at all times
is without a doubt Booma even in the
books it's very clear that their
friendship is extremely strong but it
seems like that the books hints at a
possibility of a romance
although the movies show a strong
chemistry between Emma and Harry it's
clear the two are just friends
with the books and many other fan
fictions show a slightly different story
in Rise of the Isle of the Lost
a descendents novel Harry teased uma
that he could be her first date if she's
lucky now we might not get more
information than this but it definitely
makes our imagine
nation go wild these two aren't really a
couple not even in the books but there's
definitely some subtle teasing going on
really makes you realize that Harry hook
isn't only wild but he's also a flirt
despite the fact that descendants books
are much longer we actually don't learn
a lot more about Harry and if you do you
have to search for subtle hints that
aren't longer than a single line this
mysterious charming character is
definitely an upgrade from his father's
while still maintaining that pirate
attitude we love speaking of his father
there's another moment that hints at the
important relationship between Harry and
his dad and Rises the Isle of the Lost
we learned that Harry is actually quite
daring seriously he tried to entice
tik-tok to bite his hand so he could
actually wear a real hook just like his
father
the crocodile really wasn't into it and
just went back to sleep
yep that's right even the crocodile knew
this idea was totally stupid which is
exactly why Harry's hook is fake but it
also shows how much Harry actually
admires his father
unlike other villain parents it seems
that these two had a much better
relationship of course we have a feeling
his story is probably much more intense
than any other kids villain story we
just really hope we'll finally learn the
real truth about Harry hook and his
backstory do you like Harry hook come
let us know in the comments and that's
it for our video thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]